hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll and
here's a question for you what is the
value of a human life this is not a
completely academic question of course
right now we're struggling with the
existence of a pandemic going through
the whole world the novel coronavirus
kovat 19 disease is causing people to
wonder how to balance getting the
economy and society more generally back
to work versus the possible cost of
deaths because people are spreading the
virus back to each other
and the answer if you want to know of
the value of human life is between about
five and ten million dollars that's the
number that economists have thought of
if you go into an industrialized country
if you look at the economic value of a
human life if you need to put a number
on it I know that in some sense we think
that life is infinitely valuable to the
person living it that's all they have if
they lose that life there's no other
loss that really matters but on the
other hand you can't just say well I
will spend all of the world's resources
to save this one person's life there has
to be a limit because there might be
someone someone else's life that also
needs saving so how do you spend your
money how do you just do that cold hard
brutal calculation and the answer is if
you want to know how much money it is
worth spending economically to save a
life it turns out to be between about
five and ten million dollars but this is
a different question that I want to
answer today although it's a closely
related question the question I want to
think about is why life has a value at
all why our lives matter that's right
we're gonna talk about the big picture
question of what is the meaning of life
why should we care about it at all now
as you know I am not necessarily an
expert on the question of the meaning of
life but on the other hand this is the
one hundredth version of the mindscape
podcast the 100th episode it's not
actually the 100th episode because we've
had bonus episodes and holiday messages
and stuff like that but this is number
100 in the numbered episodes of
mindscape so I thought it'd be worth a
little self-indulgence if you like I'm
going to treat myself to be able to talk
about a subject which I'm not an expert
in but I have thoughts about
and that's very much in the spirit of
mindscape you know on the one hand I
want to talk with experts who have
something to say who knows something but
on the other hand I want to encourage
everyone to talk about everything I want
to talk about it in educated way but I
don't think you need to be an expert to
have opinions on things no matter what
your level of expertise is by all means
have opinions and talk about them with
other people just being willing to
update and change your opinions when
experts explain to you why you're not
right so we're gonna explore the a big
topic the topic for which there might be
no other topic that is bigger okay
this isn't not necessarily about finding
the final answers to the meaning of life
about thinking out loud thinking about
the issues that are relevant both
scientific and philosophical because
they both matter and that's what we'll
be talking about how things matter why
things have meaning at all
now I can't let you go quite into the
podcast without admitting and and
acknowledging there were in a very
strange time right now not just because
of the quarantine but you know worldwide
things are going on not just climate
change and threats to democracy
worldwide but as I record this we're in
the middle of protests and violence in
the United States sparked by the killing
of George Floyd by police in Minneapolis
I just myself went through my first ever
curfew citywide last night in Los
Angeles we were told not to leave our
houses between 8 p.m. and 5:30 a.m. it's
a different thing than being under
quarantine where you're told do you know
stay at your house in the sense of not
going out and socializing but you can
still go out to you know do shopping and
other necessary things this was a
different situation for very very
different reasons and in a sense it's a
related reason right the movement that
started a lot of these protests came
from the black lives matter movement the
point being
of course everyone you know the wise
guys say well all lives matter yes that
misses the point the point of the
movement was and black lives matter ARB
lives black lives our lives they should
matter just as much as any other lives
and there's a feeling that I'm not gonna
get into today but I'm broadly
sympathetic to that we treat black lives
in certain other lives here in the
United States as being worth less as
mattering less and I think that is a
problem a mistake not what I'm gonna be
again facing today but I do want to
acknowledge it and I also want to
acknowledge that it's a complicating
factor when you want to talk about
science or philosophy or for that matter
art or cooking or whatever to
acknowledge that the world is going
through struggles outside and those
struggles don't hit everyone equally
some people are struggling more than
others and I do appreciate that and so
there's a question of whether or not
anyone should be thinking about abstract
philosophical issues or you know
cosmology or particle physics when
there's police brutality and shops and
restaurants being looted on the streets
of the country that you're in let me
just say that it is exhausting it is uh
it can be really wearying really trying
to not just to live through the
realities that we're living through but
to fight against them to try to make
things better
right and if there's any direct
relationship with what I'll be saying in
today's podcast with what's going on in
the world around us it's that I think
the lesson at the end is that the
struggle is worth continuing that as
exhausting as it is as tiring as it is
as distracting as it is from other
things you might want to be
concentrating on it is worth the effort
to keep your chin up and try to make the
world a better place we might disagree
with each other about what that
systematically operationally means to
make the world a better place
but we should be able to agree that it's
worth the effort and it's worth saying
even though sort of it can sound trite
but it's worth repeating because it is a
struggle it's a real struggle it
different people have different
capacities for dealing with it in
different ways and that's important to
recognize so I'm not about you know
upgrading anyone elses choices about how
to deal with this situation but about
encouraging those who are trying to make
the world a better place to make their
individual lives better to make
lives better of everyone around them
that is something very worth doing that
does have meaning that does matter so
with that let's go
[Music]
those of you who listen for a long time
know that I'm not somebody who thinks
that science can answer every question I
love science it's what I do it's very
very important but science has a role
and that role is figuring out what
happens in the universe what the
universe is made out of how that stuff
behaves how it interacts how it changes
in other words the role of science is
descriptive rather than prescriptive the
role of science is not to say what
should happen is to say what does happen
nevertheless even when we're talking
about an extremely philosophical topic
like why does life have meaning and what
is that meaning it's my predilection I
cannot possibly stop from first thinking
about the science behind it in this case
if you're gonna say you know what is the
meaning of life then you can sort of
equivocate a little bit about the
meaning of the word meaning and rather
than talking about meaningfulness in
life we should perhaps start by talking
about the meaning of the word life the
definition what is what is it that we
mean when we say the word life and one
of the great things about this topic is
because it's so broad ranging I'm gonna
get a chance to remember a whole bunch
of things that we've said in previous
podcast episodes with previous guests so
we've talked about the meaning of the
word life in the context of life on
other planets a little bit we talked
about it with Kate Adam ala with Sarah
Marie Walker with Kevin hand all of whom
were thinking about exobiology and life
on other planets
but we sort of skipped by the details of
that discussion we brought it onto the
table thought about a little bit and
moved on we haven't had a focused
discussion on really what we should mean
by the word life when is some thing in
the universe qualify as being alive
versus not being alive so I mentioned
that because it will be a future podcast
episode I think that's an important
thing to focus in on so we'll be talking
about that but for today we're not going
to necessarily need the once-and-for-all
meaning of the word life what we're
gonna need is some properties okay some
aspects some features of life they'll be
relevant to this question of what is the
meaning with the capital M of our
individual lives so I'm not gonna you
know there's a big there's a lot of
background here okay
it's gonna matter a lot for example
whether the person asking this question
is religious or not in principle and I
do not want to spend time justifying my
personal beliefs about religion and
otherwise I I think that's a thing worth
doing but not in this particular episode
of this podcast so rather I will just be
telling you what they are so that you
know what my commitments are as they say
in the philosophy circles they are to
what you might call naturalism in
particular physicalism that is to say
there is only one world the natural
world people sometimes think that it's
hard to define naturalism because you
know what do you mean what how would you
know if something was supernatural non
natural or not I don't think that's
something that's difficult to define
about naturalism I think what is it was
actually difficult to define is super
naturalism when would you know that
something did not fit into the natural
order of things
but that's okay again I'm not trying to
you know find the once and for all
definitions I just want to tell you
where I am coming from and so my version
of naturalism is physicalism by which I
mean there is only the physical world at
ground so in contrast people like David
Chalmers or Phillip Gough would at least
previous mindscape guests who talked
about consciousness and Pan psychism
they would at least be open to the idea
that in addition to the physical stuff
of the world the material stuff that
makes us up there are also mental
properties even if there's only physical
stuff even it's not a dualism between
physical stuff and mental stuff they
would still argue that it's at least
conceivable perhaps even advisable to
imagine that physical stuff has mental
properties as well as physical
properties so I'm not going there that
is not where I am coming from I'm
imagining that when we talk about life
we're talking about something that is a
hundred percent physical all the way
down and it's important that we've
learned as we learned about physics and
biology and other things we've learned
something about that particular thing
that we call life most importantly it is
fundamentally a process it is not a
substance so not only is there no
separate mental realm like Descartes
might have imagined where there's a
disembodied mind
somehow communicates with your physical
body in a very obvious kind of dualism
but there's also no kind of fluid or
stuff that qualifies as living versus
nonliving
living is a property that different
kinds of material can have under the
right circumstances and this is a very
traditional common move in the progress
of science we realized it's something
that we thought was a substance is
actually a description of some kind of
process a famous example is heat right
it used to be thought that heat should
be thought of as a fluid that could move
from one thing to another and the name
of that fluid was called caloric and
this makes perfect sense in a lot of
ways if you take two blocks of metal one
is hot one is cold and you put them in
contact with each other so they're
touching they equilibrate the hot one
becomes a little cooler the cool one
becomes a little warmer and what it is
exactly like is the flow of a fluid from
the hot thing to the cool thing it's
like if you have two tubs of water and
you connect them by a little tube they
will reach an equilibration where both
of the tubs have the same level in
between right so it's not crazy you're
obviously wrong to think of something
like heat as a substance but then you do
the science you learn what it's actually
made of you realize that all this stuff
is made of atoms and the atoms have
little jiggly motions that you can't
keep track of and what you mean by heat
is the average thermal energy in those
jiggly motions so it's a description of
what is going on in the actual stuff but
the actual stuff are the atoms it's not
a separate thing that is the heat
likewise for life you know just like
heat you would not be completely crazy
to think a priori that life was a thing
and it was in some things that we called
living organisms and that life was not
in other things right some along the
tall or life force that left your body
when you died again not completely crazy
but also not correct that is not how
life actually works in the naturalistic
point of view that we now have that I
now have people agree with me now have
that I discussed a great detail in my
book the big picture if you want more
details here life is a way of
gang about certain reactions certain
dynamical processes characteristic of
certain kinds of collections of atoms
and particles and physical stuff okay
again I'm not here to justify these
statements just letting you know what
they are but we can take a little bit
more deeply you know it's not just that
life is a process it's a particular kind
of process but I process what I mean is
you know some people ask I did a debate
years ago about whether there's life
after death one implication of my view
on what life is is that there is not any
life after death because life is a
process and the process ends when you
die there's no place for the information
that contained the essence of you to go
when you die in your physical body
ceases to exist there's no mechanism for
that to be preserved outside your
physical body and one of the questions I
get in a debate like that is well
smart-aleck where does the energy go
when you die like when you're alive you
have energy right you can move around
you can run you can jump when you die
you can't so where did the energy go and
from this perspective of life as a
process there's a perfectly reasonable
answer to that which some people get
then a lot of people and seem to not
quite believe when I give it to them but
the answer is the same as where the
energy goes when you turn off a
flashlight or where does the energy go
when you put out a candle the answer is
it doesn't go anywhere it's still there
the energy is not a fluid either the
energy is a description of stuff and the
energy stopped doing something that it
was doing right it's not that it went
away when you have a flashlight with
batteries inside you turn the flashlight
on the batteries are doing something
they're making electrical current flow
through a filament and lighting up
extending photons through the room that
you're in and when you turn the switch
off the energy doesn't go away it just
stops doing that particular thing when
you turn off a candle there's a chemical
reaction when the candle is burning that
is you know converting the substance of
the wax of the candle and combining it
with oxygen in the process of combustion
and it's giving off light and heat
thereby and when you put the candle out
the energy that is locked up in that
wacks that could potentially burn just
stops burning it stops changing that
particular way it stops that particular
process so that's what happens when we
die right dying is part of living it's
something that's going to happen to us
all and it's a cessation of a certain
set of chemical reactions going on in
our body okay and that leads into the
fact that life is not just any old
process but it is a particular out of
equilibrium process so there's a lot of
processes I mean the word process is a
very broad thing you know the planets
going around the Sun or is a process in
some sense but no one is going to
mistake planets orbiting the Sun for
being alive just on the basis that
they're moving okay one of the features
of a living organism is that it is an
open system a living organism exchanges
energy but also information and
influences with its surroundings so a
living organism is a certain kind of
physical object which manages to
maintain some sort of structure even
though it is changing over time and
there's different kinds of change in a
living being right I mean it can change
just by walking around and moving some
of us can anyway like a tree maybe isn't
very good at that but living beings can
grow some again some of them individual
cells maybe don't grow very much but
multicellular organisms certainly do and
living beings can change you know just
from day to day you can go to sleep and
so forth that's a certain kind of change
but it's a very specific kind of change
it's not simply motion it's kind of a
maintenance of a structure over time
that would not necessarily have been
maintained under ordinary circumstances
Erwin Schrodinger who I've talked a lot
about in the last year or two in the
context of quantum mechanics you know
later in life he wrote a little book
called what is life and people made that
book very famous it was a wonderful book
to read this is the 1950s before we knew
about DNA or anything like that but
rigor in some sense predicted the
existence of DNA because he said there
must be a way for information to travel
from generation to generation and what
kind of physical system can do that I
mean we knew that information travel
generation
raishin for a long time but Schroedinger
as a physicist is saying what kind of
actual information carrying substance
could it be and he figured out that it
needs to be some sort of thing that was
rigid enough to be kind of like a
crystal it sort of lasts from generation
to generation
but it can't just be a regular crystal
it can't be something that is the same
over and over again because no
information is conveyed by passing on
something like that so it has to be what
he called an a periodic crystal
something that has structure has
information but is not just repeating
the same structure over and over again
and that's basically what a DNA molecule
is a DNA molecule is a list of little
base pairs in a particular order that
can be preserved from generation to
generation I like to pause for a second
to talk about policy genius you might
think with everything going on in the
world right now will be an especially
bad time to buy insurance maybe the
rates are impossible to figure out maybe
some companies aren't even selling it
but the opposite is true policy genius
makes it very easy to figure out exactly
what is affordable to you what is right
for you what is appropriate for you for
things like life insurance auto
insurance home insurance what do you do
is you go to policy genius.com
and you can compare quotes from top
insurers to find the best price on a
policy that would fit you and policy
genius has a team that does all the
paperwork they cut through the red tape
for free if you hit any speed bumps
during the application process they will
be there to take care of everything
so if you're one of many people looking
to buy life insurance right now but not
sure where to start
head to policy genius calm they'll find
you the best rate they'll handle all the
details they'll get you and your family
protected hopefully giving you one less
thing to worry about
sorry god that was a little bit of a
digression that's a very important part
of fertig errs book but I think that an
equally interesting part of his book is
his answer to the question in the title
what is life and that gets a lot less
attention and I'm not going to get the
exact quote here but roughly speaking
which rüdiger says is that life is a
physical process that continues on long
after it should have stopped now that's
a contentious kind of definition to give
because what do you mean should have
stopped
after all the earth goes around the Sun
for millions and billions of years it
never stops like how do you know when
something's going to stop
but what Schrodinger is trying to do is
to distinguish between something like a
ball rolling down a hill which is an
open system the ball can bounce it can
emit noises there is friction etc etc
and the ball will generally roll down or
rock or whatever rolled down to the
bottom of the hill and stop it will not
pick itself up and climb back up the
hill where as a living being when you
feed it when you give it the stuff it
needs from the outside world can keep
going a person unlike a rock or a
boulder can not only go down the hill
but then back up and then down and then
back up again and not in a simple way
it's by taking in free energy from our
environment that's why in Schrodinger's
book he talks a lot about entropy and
free energy very roughly speaking you
all know if you're listening to this
podcast that I like entropy and it's a
measure of the disorderliness the
randomness of a physical system and very
roughly if you have a system that has a
total amount of energy you can divide
that energy into the high entropy energy
the useless energy that entered the
energy that is in the form of just heat
and random motions and then on the other
hand what we call the free energy the
energy that is locked up in some way
that can be used to do work like climb
up a mountain or something like that and
the Schrodinger tried to relate that to
negative entropy and I don't really
think that's very helpful but the point
is there's useful energy free energy and
useless energy and tropic high energy
high entropy energy and so what
Schrodinger is saying is that what a
living being does is take in free energy
from the environment whether it's
through photosynthesis you're out there
in the Sun taking free energy from the
Rays of the Sun or we human beings might
you know eat other organisms and get
free energy from there and we use that
to maintain our structure so if you
think about it you know a person can sit
still a well-trained monk or meditator
can sit extremely still and you know
appear from the outside not to be moving
but that's a different kind of stillness
than a chair or something like that a
chair maintains its
on the basis of the fact that it is made
of things that are not themselves moving
right a chair is made of little pieces
of wood which is made of molecules which
are basically sitting there in the same
configuration over and over again you
might call that a micro static kind of
sitting in place whereas an a living
organism is not micro static because no
matter how good you are at slowing down
your breath and your heartbeat and not
itching or anything like that not
wriggling in your seat there's still
processes going on inside you your heart
is beating you are breathing ATP is
being generated blood is moving through
your system signals are being sent for
through your neurons and so forth all
that is happening beneath the surface
while maintaining in fact the point of a
lot of these motions is to maintain your
basic continuing continuity of physical
structure so remember when I talked to
Antonio Damasio and he emphasized the
role of feelings in the maintenance of
homeostasis so that's what a living
being has a living being has a
homeostatic kind of stationary
continuous existence versus a micro
static existence we can be more or less
the same so which further is getting at
we can maintain our structure our
integrity over time not because we're
made of things that are stationary but
because we're made of things that are
churning around doing the work keeping
us in a more or less continuous
structure and that's what Damacio thinks
of as the origin of feelings he thinks
that feelings are ways that our bodies
or our brains feel that we are deviating
from the place or the equilibrium we
want to be in and then we sort of move
back toward it okay that's what
homeostasis is the restoration of that
sought for equilibrium structure and
something that is very very important
about how life becomes homeostatic is
that it is through processing and
exchanging not just energy with the
outside world but information so a
classic example of a homeostatic system
is a thermostat okay you put a
thermostat
your wall you said it and you say keep
it between 71 degrees and 72 degrees
Fahrenheit for example okay and that's a
very simple straightforward thing
there's a very not very complicated
mechanical gizmo inside that will adjust
the heat or the cooling to keep you at
the same temperature and that's
homeostasis but the kind of homeostasis
that a living organism goes through is
much more elaborate than that right
we're constantly getting information
from the outside world and from inside
ourselves exogenous and endogenous if
you want to be technical about it and
we're adjusting in very complicated and
subtle ways not only are we just
immediately regulating the temperature
of our bodies but we're also thinking
and we are reacting in potentially
complicated ways to the world around us
okay so I'm building all the subjects I
want to emphasize that part of being a
living being is this maintenance of a
structure over time through processes
through things changing and part of that
is thinking and in from end and reacting
to the world in ways that involve the
exchange of information learning about
the world contemplating the world simple
organisms will do this in extremely
simple and perhaps trivial ways more
elaborate organisms will do this in much
more elaborate ways and at the end it
ends this is a feature of life that I
already mentioned one feature of life is
that it is temporary okay we're all
going to die I had a podcast about this
too with Megan rosenbloom about the
death positive movement facing up to the
fact that one day we are all going to
die from a cosmic perspective even
something like a bacterium which you
might say bacteria are immortal right
they just sort of split and they don't
die of old age you can kill a bacterium
but they don't die you know they don't
run out of their ordinary lifespan they
just undergo fission into two bacteria
but cosmically speaking you know the Sun
is gonna burn out everything's gonna
fall into a black hole the black holes
will evaporate at some point every
living organism is going to cease to
exist
so whatever the meaning of life is it
can't involve a search for permanence in
any real way
you can't achieve permanence in life
whatever the meaning of life is it's
going to have to face up to the
scientific fact that life is temporary
okay again given my commitments to
naturalism and physicalism and so forth
which I am very very committed to okay
so that's I think all we need to know or
think about about the nature of what is
life but I do want to talk about a
little bit more detail about this
feature of life that we exchange
information and we think about the world
because that comes into this notion of
emergence that is crucially important
again in the big picture I talk about
emergence at great length and one of the
important features of emergence I mean
very roughly speaking emergence is a
sense in which at a higher
coarse-grained level of description
there are patterns that describe what
happened which might not have been
immediately evident if you just look at
the microscopic fundamental level okay
now there's a lot of debate and dissent
and disagreement about what we should
exactly mean by the word emergence and
then people go around defining weak
emergence and strong emergence and so
forth and I'm not going to get into all
those fascinating questions right now at
the technical level what I'm referring
to here is weak emergence okay not
strong emergence but what I want to get
at is the point that these emergent
higher-level descriptions can be of a
completely different character than the
lower level descriptions so a classic
example of emergence is if I have a
bunch of atoms in a box of gas I can
describe them using kinetic theory I
just described every atom I know where
it is
okay has a location and I know it's
velocity or its momentum and then in
principle I could use the laws of
physics to say what all the atoms are
gonna do using Newton's laws or whatever
quantum mechanics if I need that or I
can average things out right I can say
well if I take a little tiny region
maybe ask Ubik millimetre of space and I
can figure out the total number of atoms
in there and their total momentum etc I
can define a temperature and a density
and a pressure in different directions
and from that I can find a description
of the air in the room in terms of a
Luud right it has those fluid properties
and I can forget the fact that really
it's made of atoms that is an example of
emergence I have a description of what's
going on in the air
in terms of the fluid that in some sense
is way simpler I need a lot less
information to accurately model what is
happening in the air in the room then is
contained in the more comprehensive
atomic description okay
that is a feature of emergence that is
absolutely central it is the appearance
of a useful pattern based on incomplete
information it's an example of a kind of
real pattern as Daniel Dennett talked
about in my podcast with him it's not
subjective okay it's not just our
inability to see the atoms that matters
there is a real structure to the nature
of the system that allows us to describe
the air in the room as a fluid even
though it does not make use of all of
the information and that's very crucial
you know my favorite example of
emergence is actually not well the yeah
the box of gas is a good one but here's
another one that seems even simpler
think about the earth going around the
Sun okay we think it's very natural that
if you give me the position and velocity
of the earth then I know and I know
Newton's laws of gravity I can figure
out how it moves around the Sun okay
we're not surprised by that but if you
think about it that is an enormous
simplification because the earth is a
collection of atoms right there's
roughly 10 to the power 15 atoms and in
principle every single one of those
atoms has a position and a velocity and
the idea that I can give you a tiny
amount of information much much smaller
than the full specification of the
position of velocity of every atom and
yet get useful information to be able to
predict what will happen next is amazing
so what I give you is the location and
the velocity of the center of mass of
the earth so I don't give you random
information I give you some very very
specific information and from that
center of mass position and velocity I
can predict the motion of the earth but
if instead someone said okay I'm going
to give you
if there are 10 to the 50 atoms in the
earth if I'm gonna give you the position
and the velocity of 10 to the 50 minus
one of them but I'm not gonna give you
the position the velocity of the
remaining one what could you tell me
about where the earth is gonna go
strictly speaking the answer is nothing
at all I mean maybe that one atom has as
much momentum as all the other atoms in
the earth combined but in the opposite
direction okay if you don't know what
that one atom is doing you can't predict
anything and that's an extreme example
but let me let me give you a slightly
more vivid example what if I told you
the positions of every atom but not the
momentum of any of them I've given you
half of the information that there is to
know about what's going on in the earth
and you can predict precisely nothing
about what direction the earth is moving
in so that's the generic situation in
physics the generic situation is if you
don't give me all of the information
about a physical system I can predict
almost nothing about what it will do
emergence is an example of this sort of
narrowing of the phase space of the
system to a very very much smaller set
of possibilities which nevertheless give
me some handle on what is going to come
next that is a real feature of the
universe a real pattern as Dan Dennett
would put it and anyway again I got
enthusiastically distracted from my
point my point was that the example of
the earth and the center of mass is very
vivid because we can understand it but
it's also not characteristic of
emergence in many other cases because in
many other cases the emergent
description might seem very different
from the underlying more fundamental
comprehensive description in the case of
the earth the description is the same
for the individual atoms you would give
me positions and velocities or for the
Earth's center of mass you would give me
the position in the velocity but in the
Box of gas example the description is a
little bit different right instead of
giving me positions and velocities you
give me fluid descriptions temperature
pressure density etc that seems a little
bit different but maybe it doesn't seem
as different as it could be the point is
that in a world where you're trying to
describe emergent properties of open
systems the emergent description that
you have might be different in kind
might be an entirely different kind of
description than what you have at the
lower level and in particular what I
want to emphasize is that the
fundamental laws of physics as we
understand them are moment to moment
they are laplacian in the sense of
pierre-simon laplace and Laplace is
daemon right if you tell me everything
about the world right now I can tell you
the next moment and the previous moment
using the laws of physics so the laws of
physics as we currently understand them
at the fundamental level are not
teleological systems do not reach back
into the past or predict into the future
very very far in order to figure out
what to do next
systems are not oriented towards goals
according to our best fundamental
physics that we have today and why I am
saying this is because wait for it the
emergent description of subsystems of
the universe might very well be
teleological there is no reason why not
okay just because the underlying
description is not teleological is just
moment moment that doesn't mean that our
best description our most compressed
most successful real pattern that we
identify is necessarily equally
moment-to-moment it might very well seem
teleological that is allowed by the fact
that we do not live in equilibrium ok we
have an arrow of time we live in a
universe where there is a difference
between the past and the future
ultimately arising because entropy is
increasing stop me if you've heard this
before
entropy used to be very low in the past
it will be higher in the future it is
changing and that gradient that changed
entropy over time allows for the
existence of real emergent patterns that
treat the past and future very
differently there's no obstacle to that
in principle and we're allowed to ask
then does it happen in practice so in in
particular I want to suggest that even
things like purposes can emerge at the
higher level of description and I'm
really gonna you know
a very slapdash job of defending this
this is a controversial idea in the
philosophy of science in general or
metaphysics or whatever you want to call
it but I'm on the side that says that
things like purposes and goals can be
emergent phenomena now I should sit back
a little bit and think about the fact
that there are different things that you
might mean when you say the word purpose
one one use of the word purpose is sort
of the use of something right like what
is the purpose of this hammer it is to
hammer nails into the wall even if it's
purely biological what is the purpose of
the long neck that a giraffe has is it
because it wants to reach it enables the
draught to reach food up there high in
the trees or is it because giraffes of
the opposite gender find the long neck
very sexy and are more likely to
reproduce for you with you or anything
like that I talked a little bit about
with Neil Shubin on the podcast about
the pressures that evolution doesn't
does not give you four different things
and there you could have an attitude
that would argue that the vocabulary of
purposes is just inappropriate when you
talk about the length of the drafts neck
you could say look what I'm keeping
track of or what I should keep track of
is the genome of the giraffe right the
genetic information contained in the
giraffes DNA and that is going to be
passed on from generation to generation
and some of it will be passed on and
some of it is less likely to be passed
on and through various kinds of
pressures the kinds of genomes that got
passed on gave giraffe longer or longer
necks over time and there I've described
what happened and I never used the word
the purpose of the neck there the phrase
the purpose of the neck is to help the
giraffe reach leaves high on the trees
my point is that it's that you can talk
that way but I can also talk in the
language of purposes at the emergent
level I can simultaneously believe that
there are no purposes to electrons or
protons and neutrons simply obeying the
standard model of particle physics and
there is a purpose to a hammer or to the
neck of a giraffe
one simple way of saying it is of course
there are purposes in nature because I
in nature and I have purposes I have I
have reasons why that I would like to do
things so there's a difference with
saying that something isn't part of the
most fundamental comprehensive
description and saying something doesn't
exist at all
but when we're talking about the meaning
of life remember that is where we
eventually want to get here we talk
about meaning in that sense the word
meaning in the word purpose are often
conflated and in fact they are very
similar to each other right they're
related they're not completely
independent but the meaning of life does
not come from a purpose in the sense of
something that is being used for some
purpose that would be or could be true
if you are not a naturalist but a theist
right if you thought that God or some
other higher being created the universe
and created human beings for some
purpose then that purpose could be
inherited by us human beings that'll be
perfectly okay that is not something I'm
going to help myself to so therefore the
idea of a purpose as a use imposed from
the outside is not going to be relevant
to my conception of what the meaning of
life is but there's another idea of what
you mean but you might be mean by the
word purpose which is simply a goal
right my purpose in doing this is to
reach this target in the in the future
okay what I care about is achieving a
certain kind of thing so that's my
purpose I'm doing this in order to
achieve a certain kind of thing and here
I think this is a relevant conception to
when we think about life in the real
world even as physicalists again you
know the example I think I gave this
example the big picture I've used this
example otherwise but think of a cat
chasing a mouse okay there's two
different ways there's many different
ways but let's consider two different
ways of describing what is going on one
way of going on of describing what's
going on is to give all of the
microscopic information about the cat
and the mouse in their environment right
all of what their cells are doing all
the signals being sent from neurons the
pumping of their heart and so forth an
enormous amount of information in terms
of which presumably you could very
accurately predict what's going to
happen next
or you can just say the cat is trying to
chase the mouse
the cat has a goal the cat has a goal
which is to catch the mouse
now that might not be able to give you
quite as reliable rigorous careful
predictive capacity but you get a lot
for very little information this is
exactly that kind of emergence that
we're talking about whenever you can
describe something with some usefulness
some amount of real information
predictive power for example attached to
your description that requires a lot
less input than the microscopic
information about the system you're
talking about then you have emergence so
if you have an efficient description
then I you know to people like me or do
people like to indent it you call that a
real thing it really exists it may be it
only exists at the emergent level but
it's never less real it is not an
illusion so to the extent that a cat has
the goal of catching the mouse goals are
real purposes in that sense are real
things it's not something it's okay to
talk about and you know to be fair there
are layers here there they're different
there's a spectrum of complexity when we
talk about goals and how they emerge as
it were so a bacterium you know there's
a famous fact about bacteria is that if
you put it in a petri dish with a
gradient of nutrients so there's more
nutrients on one side of the dish then
on the other side of the dish the
bacterium can figure that out
the bacterium can move itself in the
direction of the higher concentration of
nutrients okay in some sense that is
operating toward a goal right the
bacterium would like to be happy and in
the region of the petri dish that has
more nutrients but that's not a very
rich sense it's certainly not a very
necessary sense right by saying the
bacterium has the goal of being in a
higher nutrient part of the dish that's
not any simpler than saying the
bacterium moves in the direction where
there's more nutrients right just as a
fact there's equal amounts of
information either way you don't need to
use the goal oriented language but as
life evolves as it becomes more complex
our ability as living beings to
conceptualize the world becomes richer
becomes more complicated so a very
simple
being a bacterium were a very tiny
little organism basically lives in the
here and now okay a bacterium does not
have a nervous system it does not have
the ability to conceptualize and keep
images of the outside world inside of
itself
there's no symbolism in the brain of
bacterium because it does not have a
brain but as nerve systems evolve and as
we evolved brains organisms extend their
reach from just the here and now to
greater sized regions of both space and
time so I suspect I'm not an expert on
this one expert on the biology I suspect
that space came first
I suspect that primitive organisms first
figured out how to represent different
parts of their physical environment
right now around them I talk in the big
picture about the example that was given
to me by Patricia Churchland another
podcast guest about a certain study of C
elegans little nematode roundworm this
study said that you know the nice thing
about C elegans is we know how many
neurons there are we've mapped them all
out it's like 300 some neurons we know
exactly how many there are not that many
and there was a claim in a study that
said one single neuron could be
pinpointed as having part of its job was
to distinguish between forces that acted
on the nematode from within itself and
doggedness forces versus from the
outside world exogenous forces so in
some very vague sense this could be
thought of Churchland says as the
beginning of self-awareness the
beginning of telling the difference
between me and the rest of the world but
of course that capacity becomes richer
and richer and richer as time goes on as
we extend our mental capacities right
and time in particular is something that
really becomes very useful when we learn
how to not just think of the present
moment but to think about other moments
in time the concept of mental time
travel
not physically traveling to other
moments in time but remembering the past
and imagining the future this is
something I've talked about in different
ways on several different episodes of
the podcast
with Janna and Ismael with Lori Paul we
talked about you know how our self
conceptions are bound to different ways
of thinking about the past and future
remember the one I had early on with
Malcolm McIver who studies how fish
climbed up onto land and started looking
around and MacGyver makes the point that
you can at least to some extent and this
is always going to be messy biology
right it's never near clear never nearly
as clear and imprecise as physics but to
the extent that you can make these
statements MacGyver wants to argue that
fish climbing on the land was in some
sense the birth of imagination because
what he says is if you're a fish under
the water you can't see very far in
front of you you can see a few meters
that's the attenuation length of light
traveling through water and you're
moving at meters per second so you have
all of the evolutionary pressure on use
to make a very quick decision when you
see something you don't have a lot of
time to contemplate alternative
possibilities whereas when you climb
onto land and now the attenuation of
length of light is basically infinite
you can see for kilometres in front of
you now there's a new option that your
brain has which is to contemplate
different future possibilities so I
believe it is true that evolutionarily
we first evolved the capability to
remember things okay there's a part of
our brain that becomes devoted to memory
to storing information about our past
experiences and when it becomes useful
to hypothetically imagine future
possibilities we basically repurpose
that part of the brain to also be a
little stage on which we can put a play
and we can imagine different scenarios
this was what you might think of as the
birth of imagination the first time when
the living being can really think about
the space of all possibilities and so
that's what opens up the possibility to
us of an emergent description of living
beings as ones that have goals because
they can contemplate future
possibilities that's a much richer thing
than a little bacterium is doing it's
not just that we're responding to the
pressures or the incentives of the
instantaneous moment and point in space
but we're contemplating a much richer
environment
of all things to do and we're thinking
about them so there's also the
importance of cognition coming in here
not just responding instinctively or
subconsciously but thinking about things
rationally and reflectively that goes
hand in hand with the importance of
imagination in the space of
possibilities now you might remember I
had a podcast with Carl Freeston who
advocates this idea of the free energy
principle in the context of Bayesian
models of the brain and what first and
wants to argue is that what our brain
tries to do is to come up with a model
of the world that minimizes surprise
okay that we want to sort of be
surprised as little as possible now and
this is tricky thing and I think that
people have trouble both on the formal
level understanding what's going on
there but also they have difficulty in
buying it because they say look plenty
of times I do things that do not
minimize my surprise like you know I I
watch movies that I don't know what's
gonna happen next spoiler alerts are bad
I mean sorry spoilers are bad I do not
want to minimize my surprise I want to
be surprised sometimes and friskin's
response to that is well sure but in a
simple organism it would just try to
minimize surprise in a more complex
organism because of this mental time
travel capacity what you might want to
do is minimize your net surprise over
the future okay you might want to
anticipate the fact that surprising
things are going to happen to you and
therefore introduce surprise to yourself
so you're ready to deal with it now I'm
not so I think I like that answer a
little bit it's not quite sufficient to
me and I'm not gonna blame Carlton it
might be that I just didn't understand
what he was trying to say but you know
it would still be true that you could
just lock yourself in a dark room and
sit there not doing anything and you
would never be surprised the problem is
not that you're imagining a future in
which you might be surprised the problem
is that you would die if you just locked
yourself in a room and I'm sure that
Carl Fuerst in notes is perfectly well
but I didn't get quite around to ask him
about it the point is that we don't
simply try to minimize a surprise that
can't be it full-stop
right we have other constraints there
are other things we need this goes back
to Damacio
point about homeostasis we get hungry we
get thirsty we get tired we might want
to reproduce we might want other people
to approve of us with there's a whole
bunch of motivations that people do have
in the moment that get in the way of the
simple goal of just minimizing surprise
so maybe you can say something like our
brains want to minimize surprise subject
to all these really complicated
constraints working at at them at
cross-purposes in some sense maybe there
is a theory in which you can think about
the origin of goals and the origin of
purposes from that perspective I don't
know but it's interesting to think about
and the other footnote here about you
know the relationship of human beings to
the past in the future
reminds me of the discussion with Astra
Taylor from a very different perspective
we talked about the future of democracy
right and why democracy is important
something we didn't talk about very much
I don't think that was in Astra's book
was the idea that it's interesting how
we human beings put ourselves under
obligations to the wishes of people who
are no longer around we in our society
say that dead people have rights rights
over in most obvious example a person
can die and leave a will and in that
will they can you know give instructions
and say this money should do this and
you know if you don't mow the lawn every
week I'm going to take away your
inheritance even after you're dead we
respect those wishes and in some sense
why do we do that I mean it's worth
asking why do we care what dead people
think they're not around to approve or
disapprove of us and partly it's because
maybe even at this advanced stage of
human civilization many of us don't
really believe that we're gonna die
maybe we think that even after we die we
still exist on in some ways and the
people who already are dead are watching
us and disapproving of us that's
absolutely maybe subconsciously part of
our motivation but I think there's a
more important part which is that here
and now as we are alive we want our
wishes to be obeyed in the future we can
imagine
again mental time travel we can imagine
that some day we will be dead and we
would like it to be true that once we
are gone our wishes for our inheritance
or whatever is are still respected and
therefore by some reflection principle
we say we should respect the wishes of
people who have already died so again
and again I think it's very important as
you know one of the foundational
features of what it means to not just be
a living being but to be a higher level
advanced cognitively living being is a
projection of ourselves into the space
of possibilities in the future as well
as into the space of what did happen in
the past and that's going to be
important coming up and we talk about
meaning okay so let's talk about meaning
I laid the groundwork as much as I could
for on the science side of things trying
to explain how I think about what it
means to be a living thinking person or
organism so but where do we get these
ideas about values like meaning I take
it that meaning the meaningfulness of
life is one of the values that we have
and this is going to be a contentious
subject you know it's closely related to
but not the same as the question of
morals morality or ethics and how that
relates to science those of you who
listen to my podcast with sam harris he
was not on my show but I was on his show
we talked about art and is something
that I talked about on my blog and in my
book and so forth in other places but
I'm on the side that says just like
David Hume scolded us about you cannot
derive aught from his and this is a
longer conversation again I'm just
telling you my commitments here not
really justifying them but my attitude
is that science tells us what happens in
the world it doesn't tell us what ought
to happen science is necessary if our
values are going to make sense because
if we don't understand what is true and
real about the world then we're going to
come to incorrect conclusions for
example most obvious one your values
might be very different if you believe
that you were created by a loving and
all-powerful God then if you believe
that you evolved through natural
selection you might believe that God has
given you instructions in the
the sense of some particular sacred text
that tells you what to do whereas if you
if you don't believe that then you think
that there must be some other origin of
your values so clearly your
understanding of how the world works can
affect your values in important ways all
I want to say is if you are a naturalist
they do not determine your values you
can't just say well this is how the
world is therefore this is how it should
be that is just a non sequitur it is
just a violation of the rules of logic
okay so what that means is that if you
live in a world where there's an
objective reality out there I talked
with Liam Guffey bright about what that
means for there to be an objective
reality out there and how to get it but
that objective reality doesn't give us
instructions it does not tell us what is
right in what is wrong it does not tell
us what the meaning of our lives
is the other thing I want to emphasize
besides the fact that we're not going to
derive meaningfulness from science any
more than we're gonna derive morality
from science is that that doesn't mean
we can't talk about it what it means is
that there is no objective grounding to
our meaningfulness of life just as there
is no objective grounding to our morals
but that doesn't mean that they don't
exist
we can subjectively construct meaning
just as we can construct morals there's
a difference between being subjective
and being arbitrary right I mean I give
many different examples here usually in
terms of something like basketball
because I like watching basketball and
playing basketball there are rules that
we invent in basketball you know there's
a 3-point line you can't double dribble
you can't foul all these things we
certainly made these rules up these
rules are not out there to be found in
the fundamental laws of physics we could
have made up other rules indeed we're
constantly tweaking the rules a little
bit but it would be entirely wrong
headed to say that therefore the rules
are completely arbitrary some rules for
a game like basketball or chess or
whatever you want to contemplate are
better than others and the reason why
they're better is because they fulfill
some purpose some goal better than
others when we play basketball we have
various goals we want to have fun we
want
to make it an exciting game and so forth
it's exactly the same for morals or for
meaning we have goals we have emergent
things that we would like to have happen
and from those we can go to construct
rules of moral philosophy or meaning in
life so in some sense the the morality
example is a good one even though it's
different than meaning and I'll probably
say this again but the reason why
morality is different the meaning is
morality has to do with other people you
know morality is how we treat others how
we want to be treated whereas meaning in
some sense is more singular it's more
for us what is the meaning of our life
it can be related to other people
clearly other people can be important in
it but if you're on a desert island when
you were literally on the only person
who existed it would be hard to talk
about morality but it would still be
very straightforward to talk about
meaningfulness you could do more or less
meaningful things even if you were alone
so they're not exactly the same thing so
in some sense long story short I think
of moral philosophy as a codification of
our inner subconscious preferences for
how we want to treat other people and
how we want to be treated so even though
I'm not a moral realist I do not think
that moral structures are out there to
be found in nature that are completely
objective and foundational I do think
that there is work to be done under the
rubric of moral philosophy namely taking
our inner preferences the various
inclinations and intuitions we have that
come from a variety of places they might
come from our biology might come from
our upbringing they might come from our
cognition you know thinking about them
and bringing all these preferences to
light to the clear light of reason so
that we can think about them okay
the role the job of moral philosophy is
to turn our inner impulses into a system
that makes sense rather than just this
and that impulse which we sort of reach
for oh I like this better I don't like
that better let's think about it let's
ask ourselves what is it that we like
better how do we want to be treated by
others let's ask other people how they
want to be treated let's talk to them
let's get their opinions and let's
figure out what moral system
we should construct I think in this
process you know and by the way whether
or not you think that is what should
happen whether or not you think that in
other words morality is constructed
rather than objective it's hard to deny
that that is what actually happens what
actually happens in the world is that
people contemplate what they want to be
the case and they talk to other people
and they try to figure out a system to
live by so admitting that that's what
happens is not the end of the world it's
not anything goes or anything like that
the good news is that individual people
have large the overlapping preferences
for how they want to act and be treated
not a hundred percent so there will be
disagreements and there will also be as
Sharon Street puts it there can be a
morally coherent caligula there can be a
person who just has moral impulses for
which the rest of us are horrified by
them and just will never agree with them
and the point is that you can't argue
them argue with them that they are wrong
on the basis of logic or science or
reason okay what you can do is put them
in jail or you can stop them from
causing harm in some way or another and
again that is what we actually do so the
fact that people who have different
moral systems than us are not making
logical or reasoning mistakes doesn't
mean that there's no hope for having
moral conversations and I think the
other thing I wanted to say about that
is when we do this process of moral
philosophy when we go from admitting
that we have certain preferences for how
we want to act and be treated to trying
to make it into a system that is logical
and internally coherent it's easy to
oversimplifying there's a very easy
mistake that can be made of the
following form my starting point is a
set of moral preferences that our
subconscious in some way that are
ingrained in Who I am I try to turn them
into a logical coherent system and then
I realize that the logical coherence
system I constructed suggests that
certain things are moral that are
completely at odds with the preferences
I started with right so here's an
example and this is a intentionally
contrived example so don't complain that
I'm not giving a review a real
example let's imagine you said something
like the following I like to be happy I
like other people to be happy when I
talk to them they like to be happy okay
there seems to be more happiness in the
world when everyone is happy therefore I
will invent something called
utilitarianism the simplest version of
which is just the greatest happiness
that can possibly exist I will imagine
that I can measure the amount of
happiness in every individual person and
I will add up that happiness maybe I
will call it utility so it's not just
happiness but some higher level concept
but the point is I add it up okay
different people have different amounts
of utility I'm gonna add it all up and I
seek to maximize utility I seek to have
the most utility the greatest good for
the greatest number that's what I want
to have and that seems like a relatively
plausible like it's a cartoon a
caricature sorry utilitarians I'm just
using you as an example here but it
seems like you know that's not a
completely crazy version of reasoning
from moral impulses to a system right
but then someone says okay I have just
realized that this particular person has
very a large number of healthy organs in
them they're a very healthy person and I
have 20 other people all of whom have
one or the other crucial bodily organ
that is going to fail soon and they're
going to die so on the basis strictly of
maximizing the happiness of the world I
should kill the person with healthy
organs and give all their organs to 20
people and save their lives and just so
that they're not made sad by it I will
do it in secret so the people who get
the organs don't know that they caused
another human life to disappear in order
to save their lives so now I've saved 20
lives at the cost of one I've increased
the utility of the world most of us
would say no I don't want to do that I
don't think that is a moral thing to do
that person who is perfectly innocent
ezza
as a right to live their life and you
know don't nitpick the thought
experiment the point is in principle
it's completely possible that we
construct a system that violates that
our starting points in some dramatic way
and what I would say
there's two different ways to go and you
say that one way to say is the system is
always right I do not admit the
possibility that I invented the wrong
system so if I reach a preposterous
conclusion I should train myself to you
know be strong enough to accept it
and some people will do that the other
possibility is I didn't do a very good
job of systematizing my moral
inclinations in the first place that's
what is trying to be taught by something
like the famous trolley problem right
the trolley problem where the trolleys
gonna hit five people but you can push a
switch that would switch it to a
different track and only kill one person
and the point is not there's an answer
the point is not that there is some
correct thing that we can derive is it
better to kill five people or one people
the difference is you know if it were
just kill five people versus killing one
person most would say killing one person
is less bad but the point is that you
have to actively kill the one person so
there's complicated more you know
elaborate versions of the trolley
problem where you have to stop the
trolley by pushing a person into the
path of the trolley rather than just
flipping a switch and the point is that
this trolley problem is trying to get at
the fact that our moral inclinations
come in different forms some forms are
yeah more happiness all around is a good
thing but other forms are individuals
have rights right individuals shouldn't
be sacrificed that's where you get
people like deontologists like a manual
conked who says you should treat people
as ends not means and people have
individual rights all by themselves that
are not subservient to the common good I
am NOT here to actually add adjudicate
sorry adjudicate between these different
preferences these different systems of
day ontology rules based morality versus
consequential this is versions of
morality what I'm trying to say here is
it's okay it's okay to have these
competing impulses and I think that the
right thing to do is to resist the urge
to oversimplify when we turn them into
our systems I do think that moral
systems should be logical I don't think
they should be internally incoherent or
self contradictory but they could be
fuzzy
they could be like I want to increase
the greatest good for the greatest
number most of the time but I also want
to protect some individual rights or
obey some certain kinds of rules and
therefore here are the guidelines that I
figured out be exactly because what
we're doing is constructing our system
we start with values then we construct
philosophical systems from them we have
to admit that the construction might be
inherently fuzzy because our own
understanding of our initial
inclinations might itself be a little
bit fuzzy all of this will have
implications for finally what we're
getting to now which is the role of
meaning the meaning of life why are we
here what are we doing about it why do
our lives matter okay again like I said
before related to questions of morality
but different also by the way different
from happiness you might just say well
if morality is the greatest good for the
greatest number I want everyone to be
happy
maybe the meaning of my life is that I
should be happy this is a turn that many
people have made in recent years you
know a more individualistic version of
the meaning of life where they're trying
to be happy themselves and I don't like
it well I don't think it's meaning
anyway like I think happiness is
overrated I think that happiness is a
good thing but I don't think it's a goal
I think that you know there's not like
the point of life is to be happy then
stay exactly that way I think that
that's a mistake the philosopher Owen
Flanagan when I talked with him when I
interviewed him for the big picture
suggested the following you know thing
to think about when you think about
people who have led meaningful lives in
the sense of having an impact on the
world you know Socrates Buddha Jesus
Martin Luther King Florence Nightingale
whoever people who have really done
something could change the world and
hopefully a positive way but we can
argue about that it's not the point the
point is Flanagan says when you think
about these people as people does the
first thing to come to mind is it that
they were happy do you think about these
people they were happy all the time
that's that's what they achieved by you
know fighting against social injustice
or something like that I mean maybe
we're happy it's completely possible
that they were happy I'm not saying they
weren't but I'm saying it wasn't the
point even if they were unhappy even if
they really struggled inwardly it would
not be evidence that they did not have
meaningful lives that their lives didn't
matter
being happy is fine but it's different
it's different than having meaning in
your life likewise meaning like I said
is different than morality morality is
more about how we treat others how we
want to be treated by others it's a
social kind of phenomenon whereas
meaning even if it's not just happiness
meaning is still individual again it can
be related to other people you can find
meaning in being a good person and being
moral right that can be the source of
your meaning but that's not what meaning
is you can also have sources of meaning
that had nothing to do with other people
you can have your secret project that
gives you great pleasure and gives
meaningfulness to your life that no one
else ever knows about and so meaning is
closer but still not exactly the same as
this idea of having a purpose or having
a goal I did the podcast with Scott
Barry Kaufman about his updated view of
Abraham Maslow's hierarchy of needs and
he wants to replace the pyramid that is
the Maslow didn't ever draw the pyramid
but the usual popularization of Maslow's
hierarchy is a pyramid Scott wants to
replace it with a sailboat which I like
because it goes back to that idea that
life is a process right the life is
constantly changing in fact I would but
but where I pushed him is that he thinks
that sort of the culmination well the
culmination of the whole thing is
transcendence I'm not quite sure what
that means but in the actual sailboat
like the topmost piece was purpose
having a purpose and I think that's a
little bit it's not quite on the nose
it's close but it's not exactly what
we're pointing at because purpose has
this connotation that we talked about of
having a goal right I mean I presume
it's not purpose in the sense of being
used for something like we're not
thinking of ourselves as hammers and
screwdrivers but I also don't think that
having a goal is the most important
point
in life because the thing about goals is
they can be achieved you can get them
right like my goal is to walk across the
street and I walk across the street and
I've done it you know meaning isn't
fulfilled by some specific achievement
you know again achieving things can
absolutely be part of how you find
meaning in your life but it's not what
meaning is it might be a driver but it's
not identical to it were I to write a
book on psychology and the meaning of
life rather than a sailboat I would pick
a surfboard I'm not even a surfer myself
I don't go surfing but I think about you
know life as a process and this idea
this goes back to the happiness idea you
know this idea that we find a perfect
happy place and just stay there can't be
the source of meaningfulness in our life
life is a dynamic process pushed or
enabled let's put it that way by entropy
increasing and life is temporary so to
imagine that the meaning of life that
the purpose of life was to achieve
happiness and then just stay there we
like to imagine that the purpose of
surfing is to sit perfectly still on
your surfboard and that's not going to
do it because you're gonna not succeed
you're gonna fall in the drink the story
of surfing is making constant
adjustments being in constant
communication with your surroundings and
adjusting trying to maintain that
homeostasis that that upright stands
that success in surfing for just a
little while and you notice something
other something else that tickles me
about the surfing analogy is that its
motion I mean you move when you're on
the surfboard like it's not fulfilling
if you just take your surfboard out
there and do perfectly calm water and
sit there that does not fulfill your
goals in surfing but it's also not a
matter of getting anywhere this is why
I'm saying that having a goal is not
quite the same as having meaningfulness
in your life like when you're surfing
you just move toward the shore and then
the wave Peters out and then you go back
and you do it again and the net amount
of distance you've traveled you've
travelled individual distance but it's
back and forth positive and negative and
at the end you come back to exactly
where you left and that's actually
better metaphor for life I think it
reflects not only the fact that life is
homeostatic and needs to respond to the
world around it that life is dynamic and
changes an important part of it but also
that it's temporary right that every
ride on your surfboard or even your
entire day of surfing comes to an end
and you didn't get anywhere at the end
of it and you know you came in with
nothing you left with nothing but still
there is something to the journey in
between even though it's not a journey
between a and B it's a journey between a
and a in a very complicated way the
journeying matters the surfing is
actually fun in some sense so finding
meaning in life is a little bit more
elevated than finding happiness and
surfing maybe you know part of your
meaning life could be surfing I guess
like I said I'm not personally a surfer
so but it's close its close to that idea
of having a goal and I think that it's
somewhat closer to an aspiration the
idea not that there is a specific goal
in front of us but that there is a
direction in which we want to move
there's some way in which we would like
our lives to be different than they
could be I like to think the more that
meaningfulness can be thought of as a
codification of our aspirations inside
our subconscious aspirations for our
lives just as morality is a codification
of our preferences for interacting with
others slightly different things but a
similar sort of parallel construction we
start with aspirations we start with
things we want to be true or directions
we want to move in and we think about
them we bring them to our conscious
attention and we try to figure out you
know what is the system what is the
reasonable way to put all of these
things together so I want to dive into
that a little bit more deeply but first
just so you know you're not surprised at
the end let me let me emphasize the
importance of the fact that in this
point of view meaning is being
constructed meaning is not objective you
know I think I've tried my best to read
other people talking about meaning of
life stuff and I never get very far just
doesn't quite speak to me and a lot of
times not necessarily all the time but a
lot of times it's because the implicit
goal in such a project is to come out
with the end and say here is the me
of life here's the answer right very
rarely do they succeed in doing that but
I don't even think that that's the
question I don't even think that's the
goal like I'm a meaning pluralist I
think that there's all sorts of meanings
that one could have if you think that
meaning is constructed by starting with
the fact that we have aspirations within
ourselves I'm gonna sort of systematize
them and figure out what they are and
then move toward them in some way those
aspirations can be simple you know they
can be as simple as a bacterium moving
in the direction of more nutrients or
they can be extremely complex they could
in they can involve very impressive
feats of imagination thinking about
different possibilities and
meaningfulness can be something that is
fulfilled from moment to moment right
meaningfulness you know it could be let
me put it this way we often think about
you know finding meaning in life and
what what instantly comes to mind is
some amazing achievement right a great
scientific discovery or climbing Mount
Everest or making a million dollars what
I want to suggest is number one little
tiny achievements can also bring great
meaning to life maybe you have a really
good doll collection maybe you make the
really big ball of twine in your
backyard okay but also there are
processes that literally happen every
day that can be sources of
meaningfulness in your life living a
dutiful and honorable life you know
going to work on time and doing your job
raising your family putting food on the
table making a good meal or even just
having experiences where you forget
about other people like that experience
of going to Mount Everest might be very
important the experience of having a
good meal that someone else made might
be important the experience of having a
really nice vacation or just hanging out
with your friends these are also things
that you can aspire to and that can
bring meaning to your life so what I'm
doing you know without yet completely
finishing the project of being careful
about what we mean by meaning I'm just
emphasizing the fact that it's not
one-size-fits-all it's not it's not that
there's some right answer to the
question what should you
or meaning what's do the meaning of your
life be once we admit that meanings
constructed by individuals then they're
gonna find different there can be
pluralistic about what their meanings
are you can find meaning and following
rules or in breaking them if you want to
go into the podcast with Michele gelfand
about tight versus loose societies
there's different ways to be successful
either individually or socially these
are V your attitude toward rules you can
find meaning in new experiences but you
can also find meaning and familiarity
right if you really like the ritual at
the end of the day of having a glass of
wine with your loved one or your family
or you like the experience of going out
to the movies Thursday nights or
whatever that's great that is absolutely
a way that you can find meaning you can
find meaning in artistic expression in
learning new things and discovery in
changing the world but also in being a
good friend doing a good job at work
keeping a happy home petting your cat
and listening to it purr okay these are
all ways that we can find meaning in our
lives these are all versions of the
aspirations that we have yeah I want to
make that cat purr when I pet it when I
give it scratches in exactly the right
place and finally it's not necessarily
in comparison with others even if you
think of you having yourself having
aspirations did you want to achieve
something in some way it's not that you
want to achieve something that is better
than anyone else again it might be I
mean maybe you want to have the biggest
ball of twine in the backyard of anyone
in your state good for you
I mean very few people find meaning in
fine and having sort of a mediocre
medium-sized ball of twine but that's
not the only thing it could be I mean
it's really I'm gonna what I want to
suggest is that it's much more a
comparison with yourself than with
others there's two important things I
what I want to suggest without saying
here is the correct meaning for to have
in your life I want to suggest that two
things are very important to it first it
I think that it needs to be conscious or
self-aware even if you're not aware that
what you're doing is finding meaning you
have to be aware that you are doing
something
that you didn't need to be doing right
that it wasn't just a necessary part of
your life meaningfulness doesn't come
from just existing meaningfulness does
not come from just surviving from day to
day waking up in the morning look
surviving day to day can be hard don't
get me wrong it can be a struggle it may
be it is all you can do and maybe it's a
struggle to even do that and there's no
disrespect if that's the kind of
situation you're in but that's not where
you get meaning from meaning comes from
I think a little bit of aspiring to do
more than just simply existing so I
think it's important in the construction
of how we find meaning in our lives to
make that promotion of our subconscious
aspirations to conscious ones to bring
them in Daniel Kahneman's language from
system one into system two from just
impulses below the surface do things
that we think about and say I want this
I would like to achieve this this is
what would make me happy again you don't
need to consciously be saying I am
constructing meaning for my life but
need to be making some choices in some
conscious way that's one thing and the
other thing is I think that meaning
should be thought of as requiring an
engagement with possibility what is that
supposed to mean I mean in some sense
look every decision you make is an
engagement with possibility if I wish I
simply mean you know if you choose to
turn left rather than turn right
you thought to yourself well there are
different possibilities and this is what
I did and this is one I didn't do for
that matter just objects obeying the
laws of physics in some sense can be
engaging with possibilities a path that
obeys Newton's laws of physics is one
that doesn't disobey it so that's it's
in contrast with other possibilities
morality doing the right thing is
different than doing the wrong thing
okay but there is a difference here I
think that the difference is that you
know making a decision might just be a
matter of saying this particular action
is the correct one the appropriate one
it does not necessarily get its
correctness or appropriateness in virtue
of its difference with the other ones
you know the path of the planets obey
around the Sun Oh
Faye's newton's laws of physics once you
know that once you know that the path is
the one that obeys laws of physics you
don't need to know anything about the
other paths there are things you could
say about them but you don't need to
know them the point of the path that you
take is not that you didn't take these
other paths the point of doing a moral
action is not it's not made moral by the
existence of immoral acts right whereas
I think that meaning is different
meaning is about bringing into existence
something that wouldn't otherwise or
naturally have been there something that
gains value exactly in virtue of its
comparison to other possibilities
bacteria don't have a meaning of life
but a human being who can say well I
could do this or it could do this other
thing and if I didn't do anything this
third thing would probably come true and
making conscious cognitive choices about
which to do that is what I would say is
the origin of meaning wherever whatever
that meaning might be again it might
just be a mode of existence right if you
say well I get meaning from being a
dutiful soldier well that's something
that you don't have to do I mean there's
there's gonna be difficulties right
there's gonna be obstacles to being
dutiful there's gonna be temptations to
not being dutiful you can get meaning
out of life by being a devoted spouse
right by not cheating on your loved one
there could be temptations that you
overcome there's all sorts of ways in
which you can bring something into
existence that wouldn't otherwise or
naturally have been there it could be
that you create a great work of art or a
great scientific discovery or you build
a company and make a million dollars or
you construct a monument it could be
that you have an experience or an
adventure or simply a life well-lived
but these are all things that you get
credit for by making choices that
brought them into existence the the key
to me to my MA in my mind you can
disagree but the key my mind to
meaningfulness is the ability to be able
to say were it not for the choices I
made that would not have been there is
an option there's some sort of
intentional cognitive diva
from the easiest most readily naturally
available path that's where I think
meaning comes from in some sense now the
ways in which you are going to deviate
from the easiest possible path are up to
you are going to be different and maybe
I'm being very very I really think that
it is a mistake there's always mistake
people making this I'm sure that I make
it also but to sort of project my
favorite things to do and say that
they're universal and everyone else
should do them right I mean academics do
this all the time academics when they
talk about a meaningful life you know
academics or people who like thinking
about things and reading books and
writing and creating works of prose and
literature and so very often that's what
I could emic say is that the place to
get a meaningful life from from you know
reading and learning and discovering and
those are perfectly good ways to get
meaning in life from but they're not the
only way so I want to try to avoid that
nevertheless the one tiny sort of
non-trivial substantive thing I will say
is that if what I'm saying is correct
that meaning is necessarily conscious
and self-aware and that it is it results
from an engagement with possibilities
from a comparison with what you did do
with what you didn't do then there's an
extent there's certainly a sense in
which harder aspirations lead to more
meaningful lives right doing something
that is a little bit more of the
deviation from the easiest possible path
leads to more of a sense of
accomplishment leads to a more
meaningful 'no sand that's easier said
than done
okay I mean sure you want to say well
yes I'm very interested in doing
difficult things but there's all sorts
of different kinds of difficulties that
we face in life you might say well going
to the gym every day or
a couple times a week or whatever it is
is difficult you know losing weight is
difficult yeah these are difficult in
very sort of manifest ways by the way
they're not equally difficult some
people can't wait to go to the gym and
in that case good for them but it's not
necessarily something that wouldn't have
happened automatically that's not
consciously bringing that meaningfulness
into their life they're just enjoying
themselves
for others it's a big struggle to go to
the gym but what I want to say is that
there are other ways in which things can
be hard and I'm thinking mostly of
thinking I'm thinking mostly of the
search for truth right the search for
what we believe to be correct about the
world I had you know the the podcast
with Paul bloom where he had this book
called against empathy and I get his
point you know he was trying to say that
empathy is something that we naturally
have for people like ourselves and that
can be distortive because it's different
than being purely rational about
morality and how we should behave in the
world because a purely rational
consideration wouldn't give extra
benefit to people like ourselves so he's
against empathy in that sense I don't
think that's the right attitude to have
toward empathy because I think that sure
it's easier to be empathetic for people
like yourselves but that's not an
argument against empathy that's an
argument against doing empathy badly I
think that in order that that there's a
relationship between empathy and the
search for truth which is not that
empathy gets in the way but that empathy
is a crucial tool in searching for truth
there's a overwhelming temptation and as
this is especially true and people like
me in people who are science oriented
you know stem kind of people right
logical thinkers people who like reason
especially on the physics or engineering
side of things we have a weakness for
simple explanations for cutting through
the [ __ ] right and finding the
simple essence of things the spherical
cows and a lot of times that involves
paying attention to some things in the
universe and not paying attention to
others this is a crucially useful
technique in physics where Galileo if
you're following my videos the biggest
ideas in the universe I'll give an
enormous credit to Galileo for saying
look let's ignore air resistance and see
what happens if we do that crucially
important for physics but you need at
the end of the day if you want to get an
accurate view of the world put the air
resistance back in and I think that when
we I'm saying this lately let me back up
a little bit as I mentioned the
introduction I'm saying this when the
country around me the society around me
is in a mess
there are literally you know violence
violent protests going on in the streets
there's police brutality there's racism
in addition to the fact that there's a
giant pandemic that is shutting down the
whole world it's a tough time in in a
lot of ways and people in tough times it
becomes harder to think in subtle and
nuanced and complex ways it becomes
easier to look for simple mottos and
simple things to say because you know
you're very sensibly anxious and sad and
frustrated and angry and you think
correctly that this is just not a time
for delicacy for taking other people's
feelings into consideration so there's
gonna be some people who see this or
that piece of video and they're gonna
see the people who they don't like or
are suspicious of acting badly towards
people they do like or sympathize with
and they will say see I was right all
along
and you other people are to blame and
you know I've said that I tried to say
that in such a way that it applies to a
lot of different people and the
complicating factor is that sometimes
they're right all right sometimes some
groups really are being picked on by
other people and they're just telling
the truth but this is all to the
direction of saying that when you say
that you get meaning out of doing
something that is difficult that is not
natural not obvious not falling down the
stairs that is actually something active
and aspirational part of that is not
just lifting up heavy weights in some
very direct physical way part of that is
making the mental and emotional effort
to understand the world in as
complicated and precise a way as
possible and that includes understanding
other people and you know not every
police officer is brutal and racist
not every protester is violent and is
looting and we need to find some part of
that part of the struggle part of the
difficult thing to do is to find the
common ground that's not to let the real
racists off the hook either that's part
of the nuance that's part of the
complication we can simultaneously say
there are legitimate wrongs in our
society that we need to work to fix and
that not every person is participating
in those wrongs and we have to make the
effort to do that living in a world
where things are going badly can be
difficult and like I keep saying it can
be tiring and exhausting and if there is
some lesson and what I've been talking
about here Lisa V the meaning of life
it's that you shouldn't give up anyway
that if meaningfulness comes from
contemplating alternate possibilities in
our lives and recognizing that there's
something that we would like to be the
case but that won't happen automatically
something that we need to work for and
that's where meaningfulness comes from
in our lives then it it follows that
there is some worthiness to doing that
to continue to try look even if it
doesn't work I've tried to be very clear
that meaningfulness doesn't come
necessarily from achieving something it
comes from aspiring toward something
sometimes we're Sisyphus and the ball is
going to keep rolling down the hill
other times we get to the top than we
achieve Mount Everest you don't know
ahead of time often times but it can
still be meaningful it can still be
worth the effort it's very hard I don't
want to denigrate or dismiss the
difficulty of the continuation of the
struggle to make the world a better
place
it's the biggest struggle there is but
it matters it's worth continuing to try
to do it different again different
people listening and have different
ideas about what it means to struggle to
make the world a better place that's
okay but it matters that we struggle it
matters that we try matters that we
don't give up it is in some sense that
what matters it's why our lives are not
just surviving are not just existing
persisting from day to day a bacterium
that's all
I can do it's only choices to try to
keep living a human being has other
choices more loftier choices more
meaningful things that it can try to do
and I hope that despite everything in
all the ways that the world tries to run
us down that we keep trying that we keep
struggling that we keep trying to make
things better I think there's plenty of
evidence that we are I see plenty of you
know even as depressing as it is to open
up Twitter and look at what's going on I
see plenty of evidence of people doing
inspirational things in addition to all
the bad things there's a lot of good
things going on out there there's a lot
of room for more I'm gonna try like I
certainly do not think that I've
achieved anything you know you know a
completely blameless laudable life I'm
trying to do better all the time trying
to understand what other people want try
to be more generous towards people who I
disagree with to try to split my time
and the most useful way possible between
doing things for me doing things for my
friends doing things for my family doing
things for the rest of the world it's a
complicated world out there but struggle
matters it is what matters and I think
that it's worth it it is meaningful
let's keep it up Thanks
[Music]
you
[Music]